- So why do you think
Dr. Strange is so moody?
This is my thing,
(Benedict laughs)
because here's, 'cause here's my thing,
this is why I'm asking,
because like I get your origin story.
Like I get why you were kind of a jerk,
but anyway,
(group laughs)
but like the doctor
situation, but I'm like,
why are you so moody?
You're like the most powerful,
like why are you so moody?
- (laughs) That's so (indistinct).
- [Kelly] Is it because you
don't have a love interest,
because I want you to.
- It might be something to do with that.
You know,
- Okay.
- every one of these films is like therapy
for these characters,
and often therapy
- Okay.
- with themselves, hint, hint,
and I think you just have
to watch this one to see,
but he learns a lot during this film.
- Okay, 'cause I'm
just, I don't even know,
I haven't seen it, but I'm
just like throwing it out there
to writers in the world.
Like I would love for you
to have a love interest again.
Anyway, so.
(group laughs)
I'm like, I just noticed someone
might be back in this film,
and I'm like, come on, but I
don't know what's happening.
(group laughs)
But how do you think he'd
do in therapy, Dr. Strange?
- He would be, I think pretty
snarky.
- Would he just do this
and disappear?
- Yeah probably.
Yeah, he'd just skip it.
- (laughs) He's like.
- If he had to,
I think he would be pretty
snarky and defensive.
I think it would
- Yeah.
- be quite a long slog,
but he'll get to it.
He'll get to it.
He's not above learning.
I think we've reached a stage
now with him as a character
where he's so omniscient,
omnipresent, and omni-everything
that he needs a check.
He needs a check-in for sure.
So this is very much
- Yeah.
- what the film's about.
It's sort of,
his evolution is very much
part of the story, so.
Yeah.
- I love it.
I'm so excited, I'm gonna keep saying it.